the newest White House comments about
the firing of the National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn are raising
obstruction of justice questions
president Trump's lawyer is now trying
to separate mr. Trump from that talk
saying it's impossible for a president
to obstruct justice Margaret Brennan is
at the White House with the latest on
this story Margaret good morning good
morning sources tell CBS News that the
president was informed in late January
by White House Counsel of
inconsistencies in Michael Flynn
statements about his Russia contacts
they insist at the time it had not been
determined that Flynn had lied a
distinction that could make the
difference
as to whether the President himself
committed a crime Trump may have
obstructed justice if in fact he knew
that general Flynn had lied to the FBI
at the same time he urged former
director James Comey to stop
investigating him but mr. Trump's
personal lawyer John Dowd strongly
disputed that telling CBS News the
president cannot obstruct himself
because he's the country's top law
enforcement officer yet past u.s.
presidents have faced obstruction of
justice charges during impeachment
proceedings I'm going to ask him myself
is there proof of that now Attorney
General Jeff Sessions
was an Alabama Senator in 1999 when he
argued President Bill Clinton had
obstructed justice during the
investigation into his affair with
intern Monica Lewinsky this matter
involving this impeachment is not about
sexual conduct
it's about perjury and obstruction of
justice the Trump White House has spent
the past several days distancing the
president from a tweet sent from his
account this weekend it suggested he
knew early on that Flynn had committed a
crime attorney John Dowd claimed he was
the wordsmith who crafted it the lawyers
are the ones that understand how to put
those tweets together yet Monday White
House adviser Kellyanne Conway suggested
it was someone else who typed it I know
that what mr. Dowd says is correct that
he what he says is that he put it
together and sent it to our director of
social media whether the crafting of
that post was the result of sloppy
wording or revealed the president
prior knowledge is now in question
sources tell CBS News that prior to
Flynn's plea the president had been
informed by White House Counsel that
Flynn's statements were similarly
misleading when he gave them to both the
vice president and to the FBI it wasn't
until the White House was presented with
a transcript of Flynn's calls with the
Russian ambassador that it became clear
he had lied Norah
Mary Margaret thank you so much